investments in global health aren't just
good for poor countries investments in
global health are something that's
actually good for the world and when
people scratch their heads in wonder
well we're not spending perhaps enough
money on health care here in America
what are we doing spending money on
helping healthcare improve and a poor
country like Rwanda the answer is that
it's an interconnected world as we saw
with swine flu and with SARS by
improving surveillance and improving
treatment by improving what happens to
emerging diseases and existing diseases
in poor countries we're actually
improving the overall health of the
world and moreover we're also improving
productivity to levels where countries
can finally climb out of poverty and not
become countries that are dependent on
our aid but rather become countries that
are improving their tax base starting to
paying for more and more of their public
services and ultimately become bigger
consumers of American products so an
investment in health is a key step to
ensuring that the world does not have
the same problems that it's had for
hundreds of years and finally getting
over that incredible hump and providing
us with a world in which kids don't die
when they're less than five years old of
preventable and treatable diseases when
mothers don't die in childbirth because
these are health issues which don't just
impact the communities in which they are
occurring it impacts the whole world it
makes everybody more susceptible to to
coming across diseases which we really
don't want to see and we don't want to
see at the levels of pandemic that we've
seen just in the recent past take a look
at something like hiv/aids it looks like
it originated in central Africa perhaps
as much as 100 years ago perhaps even
longer ago but we didn't know about it
until the early 1980s because that's
when it came up on our radar screen if
we've been investing in health care
systems more effectively in central
Africa and in sub-saharan Africa we
probably could have picked up on that
emerging epidemic much much earlier and
we could have done more to stave off
that epidemic from
reaching our shores